the idea that uh someday I may not be
there for my family when they need me
was for me such a painful thought as if
the physical pain of living with
terminal cancer wasn't excruciating
enough Thomas hartle also suffers from
crushing anxiety knowing that he's
approaching the end of his life the one
thing that has helped him deal with it
is treatment every few months with
psilocybin one of the active ingredients
in magic mushrooms it allows me to
address some of the problems that are
what I would call a real emotional Hot
Potato hartle was one of the first
people in Canada to be granted a federal
exemption to be treated with psilocybin
it came directly from the health
minister in his case former Minister
Patty haidu the exemption lasted a year
it expired more than a year ago and ever
since a lot of radio silence he has yet
to hear from current Minister Jean Eve
duclow and health Canada gave hartle no
reason and no update they didn't reply
to our request for comment but confirmed
to the Canadian press that requests from
hartle and hundreds of others are still
up in the air meanwhile just about
anyone can get direct access to
unregulate mushrooms without even
looking all that hard there are sites
online to buy micro and macro doses even
brick and mortar stores have popped up
routinely get raided by police and
opened back up again it's very
reminiscent of the days before cannabis
was legalized and many feel it's only a
matter of time before magic mushrooms go
the same route though this U of T
researcher feels much more study is
needed aesthetically I don't think
they're going to wait the 10 or 20 years
it takes us a scientist to get that
story together in the meantime hartle
has been working with a group of medical
professionals called theracil which last
year launched a charter challenge
calling on the federal government to
Grant psilocybin access to patients in
need they say not doing so violates
their rights so why not turn the tables
and go the illegal route himself hartle
doesn't want to risk unregulated
unstandardized treatment why would we
spend our time encouraging people to do
the illegal things when people could be
encouraging change in the law itself
mark carcasso news